Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier
and welcome back to Prey. Now this play- aaoooh.
[listening to stuff about Russians]
Anyway everything is freshly NON-blown up
so I need to get a move on.
Um, unfortunately I don't know if I'm gonna find out what happened to her father,
not sure if it will all mean something if I
"Blow all this place up."
But the one thing I gotta do is
I gotta go to the Neuromod division
So I can get this damn-
AAaaahdeern
(Loud spooped markiplier sounds)
Ohhhhh my God
Am I even going the right way?
Ohhh my God
That was so scaaary
Why were you so scaaaaryuuhh?
I need to figure out if I am going the-
no that's the "Hardware Labs"
Good God
You Mamma Jammas I need to go in the Neuromod Division
Which is where I came from
Oooohh- aaaaAAAH
Aaaahhhh ayaya
AHHHlyeye
Oh god, a little wonky there, but okay
EEEEeeehh- okay
So that's where I first woke up from.
The Neuromod Division! Hooray!
Now we all know where that came from
So, If we go in here we should be able to get the
lockdown lifted on the DRM pattern for the
neuromod fabrication plan-
Whatever yada yada
I'm using big words because I'm trying to sound important.
Either way I need to go in here real quick
and then I can get back to the Arboretum
to be able to- I don't know what I'm gonna do exactly
but I'm gonna be able to talk with my brother
and I don't know if that's gonna be a happy family reu- ohhh
Hi, you weren't there before were you?
Morgan, Dr. Igwe. Are you approaching
crew facilities if so this is a
sentimental request well my collection
the gallery of photos the others used to
laugh at. Each picture is a decryption
key to a set of neural data connectors
but guess who came to the station among
them Lightner the pianist
is... is dead-
ohh okayy
We can't let those skills be lost. It's all that's left of them.
Please. Morgan... If you can
I would be grateful.
Okay, don't know if Imma be able to do that.
...open the safe in my room.
Okay thank you.
Okay maybe I'll do that.
Ooooohhhhh
Okay, thank you I get it.
Alright I get it.
I just need to know where I'm supposed to go for this.
I need to get my optional objective done
because I need to fin- errrrr
Wher- eeerrrrr
Where the heck is it?
I need to get the thing unlocked in here
Where the fuck is it??
THERE WE GO!
I need this so I need to look for that, alright
Copy Prot- Ohhhhhh
AaAhhhh
I need to go up there
Good, Good, So it's not gonna be too far
Ahh AHH
AaaAAH- OooOAHhh
Ookay- fuck
OH HEY HI
OooOHHAYHH
AYAYYAYAY
hey, HEY, HEYY
Get shreked biaaaattch
Ohhhhh noooo you got 'splode
Okay
Jesus these guys are jumpin out of the walls at me
I don't much appreciate it-
Ooohoohoho
Ohh I don't remember it being this dark in here
ooOOOOkay
Oooooohh Boyy
OH BOY
ohhh boyy
Ah
okay..
uuuuuggggghhhhhh
what happened in here?
Oo
I don't like any of that...
So much FOOD
So much incredible lovely FOOD
With which I can stuff in my pants!
And then carry with me and then break down to it's base materials
because I'm a weirdo like that
I'm an alien! I don't actually need to eat the food
Just need to carry it with me
So I can feel good about my-
ooooAHAH
okay.. OOOHEYY
aaalllright...
Good thing I don't need to aim with this shotgun
Just general direction is good enough apparently
Okay...
AHH fucking GAWD DAMMIT
Alright fine, you wanna be like that? Euuughh
Oh hi, what are you?
OOOOHHH
Ohhhh oh oh ohhhh aghh
awwwwww
That's no good at all
oh that's no good at all
Okay so power's out here
*strange noises*
I don't wanna know what that was
Sounded bad
Okay so, nothing here
This doesn't look like the place I'm supposed to go
Why am I- WHY AM I WALLOWING IN THE BATHROOM
When I don't REALLY need-
FUCKING DIE
OW I'm aware of that, thank you
Assholes just poppin' out of nowhere
Plenty of lockers to suage(?) my feelings
My emotions were highly DAMAGED in that surprise attack
Okay, anything else?
God, there's so many crews
Uh
See, it doesn't seem, though,
This seems like a lot of crew quarters but
it doesn't seem like there's a lot of different places for with which there to be people
Considering there's like an endless supply of people on this station
You know-
*gasp*
AYYY OHHHHHH IM UP NOW
I don't want to be up
Okay, where are you at?
ooooohh, where you at?
Wooaahh NO- AH OH AH
HEEL- WUUUBLAMP
I can make a lift field now, that's pretty good
BAM BLAM WHAM
Hooooooooo
Okay, got you good, you stupid sack of SHIEEAT
Sneakin' around in the dark like that
Habitation pods, not where I need to be
Restricted
That's a thing, there's something in there I need though
ooooooh, but how would I get in there?
I never figured out how to get past these stupid pieces of shit
So, there's gotta be, like, a side entrance in there that I can sneak around in
There's gotta be because- OH NO it's not in there!
Oh, what am I doing?! That's dumb!
It's not in there, it's over here
Euuugh I'm dumb
Nevermind me, nevermind me everybody
But there's gotta be a way to turn off the power there
If I do need to go there
Let's try to figure something else out
I need to go over there
I don't exactly know where there is but,
Hey, I can hack that no- NO I CAN'T
But I think I can figure out to because I'm pretty sure I got enough neuromods to be able to do that
I got seven!
I need eight, eight?! Eiighhhtt?
Fuck you, eight!
Ughhh god dammit- is that the neuromod division?
No, that's fabrication so maybe that's not where I need to go
Okay, where on the map is this damn thing?
Where is it on the map? Ohhh that's helpful, it's on level 4?
How the hell do I get to level 4? God I don't even know
OooOOohh that looks promising
Nawww that's not promising
Oooo
Ah
Ooooh
Okay.. Oh I'm in a new area! So that's nice! OOooohh
Ah, I turned on the power to the uh, the place over here
Please let there be one neuromod here
I just need oooonnnneeee
Naaaawww I need one- oooohhhh
Where'd you come from?
Alright, I'll be with you in a second
Let's see, Ms. Goodwin, I'm going to need more support. The volunteers are agitated.
More than usual. This morning 16 threatened to bash my head in if I didn't let them out to stretch his legs.
When you get up here the keycode is 770, not the old number on file.
I'm pretty sure they've been watching me punch that in, so I changed it.
Let's see, John, Thanks for reaching out! I've asked Chief Elazar to send a team to do a quick once over of the premises to ensure that you are absolutely safe during the next shift.
Obviously the safety of both our volunteers and our security staff is our number one priority!
We unfortunately can't post any more security personnel to this location at the time.
But we're looking to expand our security staff and may be able to revisit this issue in the future.
Let me know if you have any questions! Bianca Good.
Okay, what good did that do?
AHHHHHH
I unlocked the volunteer quarter access. I don't know where that is
Or why that is or
What even is in here?
Why is this here?
Why was this open?
Can I go uuuppp?
Ohh I can
Well I don't know if I can
But I'll try
*Gloo cannon noises and Mark moaning*
Okay
Hello
Where am I- OH hey! Ayayayayay!
Oh *random noises and moaning*
How 'bout you don't
Oo hi how's it there
You waved at me- oo
Huh, standing up like a hooman? (human)
Nah, ain't gonna work on me
Where am I now? Ooo-
Hi Servator(?)! Hi on the floor-oooh heya
Boom!
Hehehehehe missed
Oooo hi
Okay, there's a lot of things out there lemme just pop over a..
Recycler charge over the little gap here
Boink!
Oh- Oh uh oh uh oh!
Hoooooh nelly!
Thank you for that- oh!
You still alive?
Oh fine I'll deal with it
Boink!
Hehahyahya
Alright they're going crazy but that's okay
doesn't hurt not at all be brandy grace
speaks happily enthusiastically there's
no henna pair plexus eating at her nerve
endings the Olympic medals lie in their
glass cases facing her like an audience
yet I still had my love of skating but
the skill felt trapped inside my head
the mods neuro mods allowed that skill
Okay
Nice, I gotta- oh hey!
Heya
Wam!
Womp!
Oh, major bumpadge on that
Woah-oh
Heey! Hey! Hey, what the fuck was that!? Ooooh okay I see you now
Okay, I didn't see you before
I'll get you
Get ready for some bullets!
How did that not get you?!
Oh, shit! Oh shit- ow ow ow!
Got so much foood!
Why is that not hitting him?
God dammit- is it too far? It's too far isn't it?
Ooh boy- ow ow ow!
O-O-OW
Good thing I got food!
It's the only thing I can say
Wooo boink!
Okay, oh fuck
Just gonna wait til my cool downs come up and then I'm gonna blast 'em
Fuckin' strategy
Ooh, you're a corpse now baby!
Okay, get down, fall down, and stay down you sack of shit
Alright, moving on!
with my life
No matching keycard? Oh! So that's Howle Dan Grave's office
THAT'S the thing that I need to unlock
So, the key to getting in there WAS undoing the power disruption
Sooo
Oooo!
Salvage but no power
Alrighty then
Hello?
Ah
That looks- interesting
I don't have leverage three
Welp
Well, graves I do need to come see ya, for a lot of things here gravey-boy
Oooo
Ah
Oh no, wait, this is where I was
Okay nevermind, fuck this shit
Not that, don't need that.
Don't need any of this
Ah
Noisy.
Nope, you're Fredrick Steele...
Oooo!
You had his office key!
Why did you have his office key?
Huh.
Well, lets go to his room and see if he has a key code before I go hacking into that thing.
But where oh where?
Oh, a fabricator.
Errrrr, Not yet
Not yet
Oh, it's up there!
That's right, I came up there.
Alright, I'm gonna go back up~
Because I got nothing better to do.
Then maybe Grave's going to have a way to get in there without me getting
leverage 3
Shruuuupty
I don't know wh- I don't know why I went the long way around for that.
Nobody questioned why I just did that..
It's not important.
Wooah!
Hey!
Down boyy,
Or girl
I don't know.
Okay Halden Graves, can you frickin' unlock the thing?
"Well where do you think you think it comes from?"
"You're sitting on the station's largest store of it, and you haven't wondered what it is that they have us injecting into our frontal lobes?"
"You're brilliant Graves, but you have the mind of an engineer."
"Good at answering questions, but not asking them."
Hey~ I could have been an engineer!
"Second guessing the Yus."
Oh the "Yus never struck you until you saw that report from Phychotronics, didn't it?."
I don't know, maybe? I don't know.
"We have four neuromods here in the test labs. We received four, signed for four, and there are four in secured storage."
"If you're saying you shipped seven,"
"I'd advise you to take it up with security and your delivery personnel."
"This isn't the first time neuromods gave go missing somewhere between fabrication and testing."
Ehhh. People want it real bad
Uhhhhhhh
Okay!
Alright, sure.
Neuromod licenses.
BOOM! Finally!
Uh, Finall-ee-hee!
Good god!
It's about damn time for that. The Fly.
Uh, I bet that ends horribly.
Okay...
I think that's everything I needed in there except-
OOHHHH, WOAH x5
The Nightmare is hunting you
Ooooo! (January talking)
(Mark.exe Shut down)
Oh my god!
Fuck! I had chills running down my spine.
"It all comes from them! Get it out now!"
Oh my god.
So what happens if I actually try to kill it?
Fuck..
Oh, lets listen to this I guess.
a minute
it's my day off yeah but can you run me
through the container docume seeds or
again mystery man please if I ask Gus
Alright. Lets do this. I'm gonna fight him.
Where you at? Where you at, buddy boo?
Where you at, big boy?
You over there? Huh?!
Wanna fight?
I don't know where he is.
Whaaa?
Whaaa!
Haha!
Ah, I can get ya!
Whoaa, I don't know what that was!
Ohhh, Buddy boo!
Oh, I' m out of ammo for that, I didn't think that would happen!
Ahh
Lets try eight? No, oh I fucked that up
Oh, I fucked that real good!
Lets try this. Lets try this beam.
WHA! OH MY GOD!
Wha, Slug down some drinks, big boy!
Oh fuck!
Whoa.
Oh, that's turning ya green!
I guess.
Oh, that's a thing that happened.
WhOA, I'M DEAD NOW APPARENTLY!
But I almost had him!
I bet I can do that better if I'm just not stupid about it.
I don't know where he went.
Whoa, hey!
Oh, shoulda done a better sneak attack!
Yeah-hehehew
Whoa
Not today!
Not today
You look like you are about to fall over and die a horr-
(Mark sound effects)
That's a lot of gooooo..
Typhon Cortex you say?
I don't know how useful that is, but I'm gonna scarf down some food and hopefully that's gonna clear up... some manduruer
Hoo boy!
Well!
I. did. pretty. good. there. and. I also unlocked the fabrication plans.
Which is pretty good for me!
Because now I can make all the neuromods I want!
Wooooo! Woohoo!
Wooo!
And I don't even need to get hacking anymore, because I just came out that I just went in.
So that's good for me
right there ok so all I'm gonna do is
I'm gonna head back I'm gonna probably
stop by my office before I go up to
Alex's office but then I am going to
Alex's office I'm clearing out all this
garbo oh my god I'm in the fire boy hey
good boy co-op is it a good oh yeah
goodness gracious goodness gravy man you
know to think that van Halen would not
be hunting me if I'd never injected any
of the alien neural not doing one
haven't had much success in calling up
more fabrication blends but I did have a
design for a psycho scope chips cos I've
been tinkering aha the honor distant
found some useful okay maybe if it's
gonna be actually useful to me
mmm-hmm we make another Moreau Mon yeah
we do then I am all about making as many
neurons possible at this point but
people can make more - excuse you excuse
you
now is not the time for that
the blue scheme you got bad and whatever
we got we can't make anything oh we can
make all the super pair kids we warrant
I'm not a satellite project dealing with
remote psychotronic signalling our PSS -
x5 I think you could smooth venerable
Zakir that matches yours plain English
look you could use it to get that new
Newington off your back well I was
damaged though you didn't define a
replacement part
they both okay well I mean I guess
that's okay they didn't agree for the
cue believe all new fusion we all do
excuse their comments they're cheap boy
it's off now they can do so much more
oh you have an in conversation right
next to me alone is reassuring me to the
Cuba yeah feel good okay groovey nobody
got children I wish I wasn't part of
this conversation
what do you know mommy's make it over to
you my power cricket what you owed me
one my governing to react on wushu okay
alright friends here we're all friends
we're all friends being friends friendly
friends thank you Mike move of Google
Dom oh who are you talking to you're
talking about my not shooting my friends
gun oh yeah then I love that all right
now I got that where's this chip chat
set set sets you were talking about yeah
chip set
chip set i don'ts give me chips out here
I'm gonna pretend like you don't know
what you're talking about
I'm gonna open this and then I think no
those only salvage it why did I make
those Ben I thought those salvage didn't
do a mineral material but apparently I
was wrong let's go away from that
awkward situation and hopefully
skedaddle on away which way do we need
to go we need to be elevator go right to
the Arboretum there
oh they don't know one more thing
got a power but okay I guess whatever
whatevs brother Grantham grin cool okay
okay okay whoa hey that was fun
why that happens really glad that
happened yeah
oh good I'm here so happy about that
can you click gun again hopefully love
that love that a lot that's great okay
so once we get in here we go straight up
to Alex's office and we have a
confrontation with him to understand
what is going on in this world what in
the hell were you thinking Alex putting
aliens in people's brains I've had it up
to here with you oh you piece of shit
all right where we are oh that's new
tactically speaking that's good Rick
okay I'm gonna shoot you now video oh
wow
ow ow ow ow ow ow can you one of those
please oh hey hey hello Danny how you
doing 9:08 plus operator direction line
okay please can you just kill me and not
push me into the open don't forget to
complete a patient questionnaire yeah
that's still oh I missed it that's why
okay oh poor medical operator oh poor
guy okay but that doesn't matter because
there's a Weaver right out there and I'm
just gonna you know I'm just gonna walk
fucking walk oh boy
alright we're fine fine fine
hey whoo hi what's the hole why okay all
right you know I'm just gonna oh we're
just gonna casually oh that's the wrong
number three seven two six and there we
go and there we go whoa all right we
made it
nailed it real good real good okay what
else is here on the outskirts of this
sumbitch here we got oh an apple I took
Alex's favorite Apple people be so
pissed I don't see anything else here oh
there's an upstairs
hello
ilex I won't be joining you don't worry
there's no trick just a gift from your
big brother it's the truth like I
promised me a while to dig it up some I
wanted to hide it from you my computer
another video give it a look and we'll
talk I'm sending you the password
assuming you haven't hacked your way in
yet okay this is uncomfortable is he
okay I didn't throw very far but
whatever I asked Brandi if she felt
betrayed by her pair of legs she nodded
not an agreement but understanding my
point because they discovered they could
map my brain but I can't accept a neural
mod myself her smile became firmer I
think that makes her gift more
meaningful it would be a year before it
was quietly decided by transpire to
receive no further neural maps connect
tones from para plexus patients citing
unspecified risks
okay kang seongjin okay oh that's nice
all these are nice here I'll take those
oh oh another thing oh good yes a weapon
upgrade kids the first thing that I
would want to lounge with clue skiddo
ski emails results of Morgan eval your
sibling is indeed different I've sent
the comparisons to you and Bellamy for
evaluation as you'll see there's
noticeably per there's noticeable
personality drift more than I'd expect
from heavy neural mod cycling it's even
more prominent because of the duration
"As requested I did not discuss this with Morgan interestingly Morgan seems unaware of these shifts."
"As an aside, I believe this poses interesting question for other applications of the Neuromod - not solely, therapy, but re-conditioning."
Lets see
"Alex, You've made it my duty to keep everyone on this station in good physical condition."
"The last time I checked sir, you are part of everyone on this station."
"By my count, you've missed the past 5 scheduled fitness tests."
"If you're uncomfortable with some of the exercises and preforming them in front of the crew."
"I can schedule you time in the fitness center where it's just the two of us."
"Remember, you wouldn't just be doing this for yourself but to set an example for the whole staff."
Ahh
bringing the matter you this oh I've
read this one actually I actually
already have ah the missing key card
Sarah I need your help tracking down a
missing key card this one should be of
your highest priority that's labeled EP
101 let me know when you find it found
it in a remote division on top of a
computer cabinet I'd say someone who's
trying to hide it along with what looks
like a bug-out bag should I be concerned
about anything it's still there by the
way
oh you didn't grab it
files oh I already had that why wouldn't
I have had that all right fine then
whatever movie we extend bridge yes
please unless that connects me to demon
then no thank you
I'm a lots of it oh my god if I don't
know this bridge would have taken so
long I would have just watched the video
anybody know it okay
main screen Oh rather of mine no it's
not accidentally blow this shit up
because I've done that before all right
what do we get my name is Morgan you
here is 2035 I'm aboard the talus one
research facility what else why are we
making this video right because my Big
Brother's paranoid psychometric data is
showing statistically significant
variance and personality patterns
between trial runs or the new neural
mods whatever I feel more like myself
than ever I mean look at this we did it
Alex it's real enjoy while you can
because in a few minutes it will all be
gone and we strip out the neural mods
and we said I know including my memory
of it no way around it let's talk about
the backup so the type and organisms
have been producing an elaborate
structure material is unknown purpose
unknown and my gut tells me it's a kind
of neural framework but externalized
still waiting on analysis to confirm in
the meantime I've given Alex the design
for a device I think could shut it down
if it ever broke containment Alex just
have to grow up here and commit you know
that to take all credit but if it
doesn't work it'll work trust me what
else we going to do blow everything up
that won't save us and if it does work
is it worth it the people that come
after us will be smarter stronger
immortal they can judge us if they want
but don't know they exist because of the
things we did
I'm ready do it
oh that's so weird
okay Wow
oh you haven't everything I've done
that's what you've asked me to do I
didn't think you'd believe me unless you
heard it from your mouth the tests they
changed you not a lot of first but
eventually the constant stripping of
your memory I didn't know who you were
anymore
all I want is it have my brother back so
we can finish what we started the device
you mentioned there's an advanced
version of the null wave it's the only
way to stop the typhoon without
destroying everything we've been working
toward we're just missing some scanned
data from the Carl to complete the
design help you finish this Morgan and
then you can have my arming key I don't
believe if you want to use it anymore
but you can have it
I love the chipset for you on my desk
you'll need to upgrade your psyche a
scope to scan the Carl I'll send you the
Scan locations oh that's so weird
that's so weird so there's like a choice
here this is the choice clam what do we
got hello I'm here now
ooh Alex's see oh there was a
maintenance bandar-log done that oops
okay so I think that Jarman key is in
here anyway
yeah might as well grab it again
a lot fellas safety avoid follows one is
persons responsible get as bad as they
probably are your only option is to
escape get the word out about what's
happening don't tell us one alex has a
private escape pod it's locked up I made
a copy of the key and hid it on top of
the data tower near the chair you know
the one I'm talking about
listen there's more at stake this time
than just us or this station if just one
of those creatures made it back home
then we're lost I keep having this dream
I'm just staring into the black between
the stars there's something there whoo
Morgan
that video was I'm still checking it
against my directives but as scanning
the coral will grant you access to
Alex's arming key then perhaps it's the
best course perhaps knowing the corals
purpose will reinforce your decision to
destroy Talos one just be careful
we're running out of time this is so
weird because I'm one thanks kid as bad
as they probably are your only option is
to escape well I don't
yeah what's happening maybe listen to
this
oh boy alex has a private escape pod
does doesn't mean locked up yeah I made
a copy of the key and hid it on top of
the data tower come here the janitor
maybe come in here you know the one I'm
talking about yeah I know the one you're
talking about there's more to take this
time than just us or this station it's
just one of those creatures made it back
home then we're lost
whoa I keep having this dream I'm just
staring into the black between the stars
there's something there I know there is
I just can't see it but it sees me hmm I
can feel it hate us mm-hmm
I know you know what I'm talking about
or you will so oh I don't know anything
me from the past I don't know anything
about nothing all I know is that I've
got a chip set now I do anyway
whoo hi you have enough Typhon material
in your system the turrets will consider
you a threat gray where is my gosh there
it is scope chipsets I need crystal
critical
I need where is it is it in the suit
ship since last chance
ah but these are what I need but I can
at least add these in on laughs and then
glass okay and then scope chipsets how
do you upgrade your scope to have more
Oh psychotronic skills will unlock more
okay but I need the shielding what the
fuck is it wait where is it I thought it
was here did I get a fabricator plan for
it or did I actually get it what oh oh
hang on a second there's got to be like
I had to have got it
notice I thought I did didn't I I
thought I did I could've sworn I did I
thought I did I did
oh hi what the fuck where did you come
from oh okay there it is then I think
okay let's replace ah replace this okay
actually I don't think it matters how
much that I have I think the dam is
excellent for me okay so how do I do
that so there's coral outside do I scan
the hats yeah right I'll try try buddy
boo hello-o
Coralie I would have unknown can I get
back no please can I have that this one
no right fine then
Oh Oh coral node I saw that well I saw
them oh I'm gonna get such a sneak
attack on you
Oh buddy boo you're not going to know it
hit you oh fuck shields it down
get them down hang on I gotta get this
oh there you go where'd you go whoa I'm
screaming in terror with the yellow wool
confusion pretty go oh wow oh he ran
away
where's this coral node I saw it here
unless it was actually on the Weaver
might have been hang on let me see if I
can hunt this thing down eat some food
first
okay whoa whoa where'd you go
damn it keeps flipping me around dad but
I get it we bring here are you
where are you damn it where are you in
the band what happened fuck is it I'm
gonna keep getting away from me like
that
what the fuck this is hiding in the
brush we go you son of a bitch oh you
sack of shit Oh
final screw that hurt a lot you go I
can't even find your corpses to be able
to salvage man about the waste of time
oh fuck dude can wear the goddamn are
the goddamn coral nodes you know what
I'm just gonna communication device what
the fuck is that
I said goddamn there oh where am I
I know where I was okay whatever I'm
going to look up the objectives and I'm
only going to get the objectives that I
want not that one not not not not not
where is ah no that's part of the main
saw in the exterior okay so I gotta go
outside which means that I gotta go down
where it's telling me to go all right
now I'll listen to you you second
all right so let's get doodle outside he
did hopefully find ourselves a coral
node and get more to the bottom of this
mystery
cuz I am interested in discovering the
truth and the truth shall set me free or
else the truth will kill me I'm not sure
which one's which at this point the
truthful even tell me or it'll set me
free
come on work with microgravity
thank you that sounds men
I'm thinking about the video Alex showed
you your brother believes that version
of you is the true Morgan but why just
because it came first if someone had
made you and I suppose your truest self
would be the one that fulfills whatever
purpose your maker intended I know
mn why it's someone that you will get
home
I hate for something if not you'll have
to invent your own purpose or have none
at all
whole family of all the things I know
about you I don't know what you believe
you have to decide Morgan who are you
okay well that's ominous and rather
serious okay all right I'm gonna scan
the coral do you know just because I'm
gonna scan it you know cuz maybe it's
good I don't know I don't know what to
think it seems like I don't know I'm not
sure what it is
like why would Morgan that's the
question why would Morgan change his
mind over time if it was what he thought
of you know what I mean it was his idea
then oh shit oh fuck I'm never going to
be able to kill the thing in time am i
oh boy oh that's not good I have known
well I don't have I will sighs oh no I
don't okay at least I drove it away
that's fine
from this platform Board of Directors
discord when of the situation here is
suppose it was inevitable despite my
efforts that's why it's important we had
quickly decisively
oh you don't okay
I'm damn it just run it go oh my god I'm
gonna die oh my god fucking hell I just
want to get to the node oh just let me
scan this node let me scan it no you
don't scan scan scan I'm out of bullets
aw fuck me dog fuck you fuck you that's
what I say to that that's bullshit one
side last seems to be enough to be able
to like this sways them from being
hassled about in their existence oh boy
that's too bad the club oh there were
not caught the black
oh fuck and come on where did he go he
ran away no he didn't he's right there
no he's gone okay one at least one put
it away okay
just go in here around that's an option
oh oh fuck off aah
Jeff was right there
ah fuck dude oh man that means I gotta
go get some goddamn health oh fuck okay
so unfortunately I got to go back and oh
my god shut up you shut up shut up shut
up okay so anyway unfortunately that's
all the time that I've got here I
actually wasted quite a bit of time this
episode just looking for where to go in
the crooner amat area and I have to
leave it is dark there why I don't know
I'm going to live just try to live just
trying to live please oh boy okay so
what I'm I do is I'm gonna find myself
some production capabilities I'm going
to restock because I am way out of my
comfort zone in terms of supplies but in
the next episode I feel we might be
approaching the end of this game so I
feel like the next video that you see
out of prey will be the final one
we'll see that when we come to it so
thank you everybody so much for watching
let me know how i'm doing the comments
below and try not to spoil it for
everybody else you can't and as always I
will see you in the next video bye